OK.
We're going to get a little
bit more detail about how
to sharpen images.
Here's microfluidic
devices that we saw before
in the flatbed scanner section.
I cropped a larger
picture, and as we zoom in,
we're actually seeing
some Newton rings, which
we're not loving, but let's
pretend that they're not there.
You know that we're going to get
Newton rings when you put glass
on top of glass,
or-- this is PDMS,
which is also going to
give us some Newton rings.
So let's just take an area,
maybe around here, just
to pay attention.
I'm going to zoom
in a little more.
Your eye should focus around
here and around the numbers,
and maybe over here.
To see what happens when we
sharpen, we go to the Filter,
we go down to Sharpen,
and use Unsharp Mask.
There are all kinds of
things, but for our purposes,
Unsharp Mask is the way to go.
And it was already set
at 128 once before.
Let's go down to almost
very little sharpening,
almost kind of the
original image.
And watch as I increase
the amount of sharpening.
You're seeing more and
more getting sharp.
But, unfortunately, what also
happens is you get a lot of,
the dirt is sharpening as well.
And we'll discuss that in
a moment, a little bit.
But we're going to go at
length about cleaning images.
For example, if I accepted this
with 228, which is considerably
sharper than before-- let
me undo it with Command-Z.
That was without sharpening.
That's with sharpening.
I hope you're seeing.
Look over here now.
Without sharpening.
With sharpening.
So we're getting some
real clarity here,
which I think is
what we want to show.
But, as I said, we are
also getting some junk,
which, if I decided
to get rid of,
let's say with
the Healing Brush.
Little bit here.
Get rid of this.
This is making
the image cleaner.
And the question is, am
I permitted to do this?
And we're going to have a very
important deeper discussion
about how much we can, in fact,
enhance scientific images.
For the time being,
let's leave it at this.
And we're going
to save the image
and clearly indicate
this has been sharpened.
And that's it.
There you go.